Colbie Caillat is taking fans behind the
scenes of her Malibu sessions the album
is just very relaxed carefree sunny
organic that kind of vibe only et Online
has the full premiere for Colby's new
music video goldmine which was recorded
while living in a beach house with all
her nearest and dearest collaborators
everyone together and just kind of
living like you you never clock in a
clock out it's any time that you want to
put something down that you want to
record something you have the
opportunity and I didn't want to be
driving in and out of LA and I thought
okay I can get my favorite musicians we
can all move in to this house with our
families and just record as much as we
want for two months and it was such a
wonderful experience that's amazing and
now you're headed out on tour yeah it's
all acoustic yeah is this the first time
you've done that it is I've always
wanted to do a stripped-down tour so now
there's gonna be six of us onstage but
it's all stripped down so there's like
three acoustic guitars we have bass than
we have percussion tons of harmonies and
it's just it's just hearing the songs
more as they are in the raw